[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous j'espère
que vous allez bien bienvenue dans le 78
nous sommes le jeudi 18 janvier voici le
programme de ce soir ce matin nous nous
sommes réveillés sous un beau paysage
enneigé il est tombé entre 3 et 5 cm de
neige dans les evlin l'alerte orange a
été levée ce matin mais cet épisode a
provoqué de fortes complications dans
les transports en commun vous étiez
nombreux à être bloqué et avec le froid
actuel William Martinet député LFI de la
11e circonscription des Evelin a décidé
de dormir dehors pour alerter sur la
situation des sans abris il exige la
réquisition des logements vacants le
jeudi comme d'habitude nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie pour le
weekend au programme de ce soir les
nuits de la lecture une exposition d'art
ou encore un concert nous partirons
également à monteljolie jusqu'au 10
février la ville s'illumine à la tombée
de la nuit sans oublier l'invité du 78
en 2è partie d'émission au mois de
janvier les mares de Saint-Quentin en
yeline viennent présenter les projets de
l'année 2024 dans leur commune ce soir
Joséphine colmans berger mère de plaisir
sera avec nous mais tout de suite on va
revenir sur cet épisode neigeux dans les
Yvelines suite aux chutes de neige de la
nuit dernière c'était de nouveau la
pagaille dans les transports en en
commun le reportage d'Aurélie lafeille
Patrick Jacques de dixmud et Clara de
Frutos ce jeudi matin les transports en
commun tournent au ralenti dans les
ivelines en raison des conditions
météorologiques à Oudan en pleine heure
de pointe de nombreux ivelinois étaient
bloqué à la gare faute de train les
lignes N et U étaient à l'arrêt jusqu'à
13h avant une reprise progressive j'ai
appris qu'il n'y avait pas de train en
regardant sur C maper pas fait attention
je pensais pas que ça alla aussi
catastrophique et et bah du coup je vais
arriver 1 He3 tard au travail ben
direction la maison il y a pas d'autrre
solution j'estime de rentrer à la maison
c'est une journé perdu même pagaille
pour les lignes l J et le rerc c'était
aussi compliqué côté bus de nombreuses
ligne étit fortement perturbé notamment
sur le réseau
grandversaill à midi la situation
n'était toujours pas revenue à la
normale à la gare de 50 an en iveline
depuis 6h du matin je suis là on nous a
dit que il y aura des trains à partir de
10h je suis rentrée je suis revenue à
10h on nous dit que ça sera pour midi
bon je suis là pour midi en temps de
voir parce queil y a rien il y a rien du
tout c'est galère on a dû prendre un
uber pour arriver jusqu'ici sur les
principaux axes routiers les chutes de
neige ont été anticipées contrairement à
la semaine dernière les routes étaient
dégagées et sur la 12 et la 13 les poids
lourds n'ont pas eu le droit de circuler
jusqu'à 10h la circulation était en
revanche plus compliquée sur les réseaux
secondaires fa en priorité les axes les
axes principaux donc sur le réseau
secondaire il y a des endroits où
effectivement la géographie les routes
sont structurellement en tente et donc
elles seront elles sont difficiles à
traiter même en journée donc il faud
évidemment être prudent ce soir pour
ceux qui rentrent sur ces secteurs moins
urbanisés des depuis 10h ce jeudi la
vigilance orange est levée dans les
ivelines la nuit prochaine aucune chute
de neige n'est prévue mais la prudence
reste de mise car il va continuer à
faire très froid si vous souhaitez
rester informé sur les interventions des
sleuses la lomération de SaintQuentin en
Eveline a mis en place un service
hivernal service
SMS allez c'est l'heure à présent de
faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir on commence avec
cette période de grand froid un député
des yvelin qui alerte sur la situation
des sansabris oui Mathilde il s'agit de
William Martinet député la France
insoumise de la 11e circonscription
depuis de nuit il dort avec d'autres
parlementaires LFI dans la rue à Paris
sous une tente de l'association Droit au
logement le campement est installé à
l'entrée du M métro Solferino dans le 7e
arrondissement l'objectif de cette
action qui va durer plusieurs jours
dénoncer le nombre de logements vacants
apporter son soutien au sans-abri et
parler de leur problématiquees en 2022
Mathilde 624 sans sans abri sont morts
en France William Martinet revient sur
sa dernière nuit interrogé par Grégory
Canalis passer une nuit sous une tente
c'est forcément difficile surtout avec
les températures actuelles avec la neige
qui est tombée ce matinon évidemment moi
ma situation n'a rien à voir avec celle
d'une personne sans abri voilà je sais
que ça ne durera que quelques jours je
sais que j'ai un bureau bien chauffé qui
m'attend après la nuit que j'ai passé
dehors la pire des choses qui existe
c'est l'invisibilisation les sans-abriis
sont chasser des beaux quartiers chasser
des centre-villees ils sont même là avec
les Jeux olympiques de plus en plus
chassé de de la banlieue bref ils vivent
leur misère isolé dans leur coin et nous
ce que voulons nous voulons faire avec
cette démarche c'est bousculer les
consciences c'est mobiliser les gens et
leur dire il n'est pas acceptable que
aujourd'hui dans la 7e puissance
économique du monde on est encore des
gens qui meurent de froid dans la rue
parce que malheureusement c'est ce qui
se passe depuis plusieurs jours on
poursuit ces informations avec une
grosse coupure de courant qui a impacté
les ivelinois oui elle s'est produite la
nuit dernière aux alentours de minuit et
à T chez les habitants de Montini
lebretonneux gui en cours saint
cirelécole Bois d'Arcy et Fontenis
lefleurri sur X ex Twitter plusieurs
personnes ont d'ailleurs signalé cet
incident un incident technique qui n'a
aucun lien avec le froid et la neige
selon enedis il est survenu au poste de
distribution d'électricité publique
situé à guyancour au plus fort de
l'incident 53000 clients ont été privés
d'électricité les équipes d'enedis sont
intervenu toute la nuit le retour à la
normale est intervenu vers 4h 45 ce
matin ça y est Gabriel les inscriptions
sont ouvertes sur parcours sup et ça
tombe bien car un événement sur
l'orientation arrive pour les ivelinois
oui depuis hier les lycéens apprentis ou
étudiants en réorientation peuvent créer
leur dossier sur la plateforme ils ont
jusqu'au 14 mars pour formuler leur vœux
d'orientation dans l'enseignement
supérieur 23000 formations sont
disponibles sur parcours sup et si
l'orientation vous stresse pas de
panique le salon de l'étudiant en yeline
et la pour vous aider rendez-vous samedi
de 10h à 18h au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline sur place vous
pourrez découvrir de nombreuses
formations parler avec des étudiants
glaner quelques conseils et obtenir des
informations c'est gratuit mais vous
devez vous inscrire sur le site
l'éudiant.fr un QR code d'accès au salon
vous sera envoyé et pour terminer
Gabriel vous nous emmenez à Versailles
oui au chateau de Versailles même qui
était vous le voyez sur les images sous
la neige ce jeudi des magnifiques images
dont on ne se lasse jamais mais le plus
intéressant mathil de se passer à
l'intérieur près de 200 jeunes
franciliens y étaient réunis pour la
finale école des petits champions de la
lecture ce concours récompense
l'éloquence pour se faire les enfants
lisent un extrait de 3 minutes d'un
livre de leur choix devant un jury le
but transmettre l'amour de la lecture il
s'agissait là de la première étape la
finale nationale des petits champions de
la lecture est programmé le 26 juin
prochain à la Comédie Française on
suivra ça on reviendra oui sur ce
concours la semaine prochaine dans le 78
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une actualité qui vous a marqué
près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 new allez on
ouvre une page loisir à
[Musique]
présent et on ouvre cette cette page
loisir avec vos idées de sortie pour ce
weekend Gabriel on commence avec un
événement les nuits de la lecture qui
font son grand leur grand retour oui
avis aux grands lecteurs ou aux amateurs
la nuit de la lecture les nuits de la
lecture font leur grand retour dans les
médiathèques du territoire organisé par
le Centre national du livre cette année
l'édition s'articule autour du thème du
corps pour faire écho bien sûr aux Jeux
Olympiques pour l'occasion des soirées
spéciales sont prévues dans plusieurs
lieux culturels au programme concert
littéraire conférence mais aussi atelier
débat tout ça autour de la lecture
Marion vaillant responsable de la
bibliothèque Albert Camu de saint-cir
l'école nous parle de
[Musique]
l'événement tous les ans
la le ministère de la Culture prévoit
les nuits de la lecture en bibliothèque
al il y a pas que les bibliothèques il a
les librairies il y a y a certains
musées les archives et c'est que c'est
un moment dédié à la lecture est surtout
à la lecture
publique la nuit de la lecture c'est un
moment aussi où on va combler les les
envies de certains lecteurs qui sont
très friants de de ce genre de
d'animation vraiment dans la localité de
proximité ce qui est pour nous très
important parce qu'on a une bibliothèque
de
proximité alors le vendredi on va faire
une vraie nuit parce qu'on va fermer à
22h on va proposer une soirée jeux de
société parce que nous avons une
ludothèque à la bibliothèque et donc on
va présenter des petits jeux familiaux
des petits jeux aussi d'ambiance des
nouveautés et le samedi ce sera plus une
journée familiale aux horaires de
d'habitude 10h 18h où là on va proposer
alors des rendez-vous comptes le matin 3
6 ans à peu près et un atelier de
d'écriture autour du cheval parce que on
a décidé de travailler
l'équitation
et à Saint-Quentin en Yveline aussi vous
avez des rendez-vous qui sont proposés
rendez-vous sur le site
immediathek.sky.fr pour découvrir le
programme on poursuit vos idées de
sortie Gabriel avec une exposition
temporaire au musée Lambinet de
Versailles oui jusqu'au 25 février le
musée Lambinet rend hommage au peintre
Alexandre jeanubois draonet inconnu du
grand public le musée a pu mettre à
l'honneur les toiles de l'artiste grâce
à une soixantaine de près de musées
français et internationaux l'occasion
pour les visiteurs de découvrir les
œuvres de ce portraitiste dont les liens
avec Versailles sont important car c'est
dans la commune que le peintre a débuté
sa carrière en y installant son atelier
parmi ses œuvres de nombreux portraits
de militaire de personnalités
artistiques ou encore d'habitants des
œuvres qui regorgent de richesses et
d'informations sur l'histoire de
versaill un weekend placé sous le signe
de la culture mais aussi du sport avec
une course à ne pas louper oui à ne pas
louper je dirais même insolite ce
dimanche a lieu la 4e édition de la toar
morning wild race aux EAU de toiri
plusieurs départs de cours sont proposés
toute la matinée alors malheureusement
Mathilde pour vous les inscriptions sont
closes mais vous pouvez profiter du
spectacle en allant soutenir les
coureurs tout ça dans un cadre féérique
puisque le tracé de la course passe au
travers des illuminations et du zoo de
quoi réchauffer un petit peu les
visiteurs du zoo ce weekend et pour ce
réchauffer Gabrielle vous nous proposez
également un concert à carrière
souspoissie oui et pour cause la musique
va raisonner vendredi soir au château
éphémère de carrière souspoissie desè
19h le château accueillera concert DJ
mais aussi installation visuelle pour
une soirée festive parmi les artistes
Axel Rigot on écoute un
[Musique]
extrait
pour assister au concert rendez-vous sur
le site du château éphéè et à Guill en
cour le weekend sera aussi festif avec
les soirées studio en scèes qui font
leur retour oui et pour l'occasion la
batterie présente trois pépites
musicales pop rock parti tout droit de
leur studio otage knock me out ou encore
gray and jbes le but de cette soirée
faire découvrir les artistes du
territoire et faire rencontrer les
musiciens et leur public bien merci
beaucoup Gabriel moi aussi j'ai une idée
de sortie à vous proposer elle se trouve
un peu plus loin à Mantel jolie jusqu'au
10 février la mairie vous propose de
redécouvrir le patrimoine de la ville à
la nuit tombée des installation
lumineuse jalon le centre-ville hôtel de
ville collégial Notre-Dame ou encore
tout tour Saint-Maclou l'objectif
apporter un autre regard sur la commune
c'est le reportage de Julien
[Musique]
Leroi un faisceau de lumière transpersce
le ciel depuis le 16 décembre leslurs
demande proposent aux visiteurs
d'observer le centre-ville de
mantelajolie sous un autre regard
collégial tour Saint-Maclou ou place du
marché Aublé une déambulation gratuite
les les emblématiques sont mises en
avant grâce à des scénographies
lumineuse et des œuvres d'art
[Musique]
numériques c'est déjà faire connaître
notre ville hein parce que elle est
méconnue ou avec une certaine image qui
n'est pas forcément la seule qu'on peut
avoir de de notre ville on a un
patrimoine culturel qui est très très
riches et donc de les mettre en lumière
ça permettait à des gens qui ne se
seraient pas ven V autrement de venir
les découvrir 10 artistes ont travaillé
sur les SEP œuvres de cet événement
projection laser sur les monuments ou
réalisation pour sensibiliser le public
les coloses de Vincent Loubert
questionne sur la responsabilité de
l'homme face à son environnement une
métaphore de son désir à vouloir dompter
les éléments des créations qui
intéressent le visiteur au-delà des
frontières de la commune on a même eu
des Lillois
qui qui sont qui sont passés à manth euh
rien que sur le mois de de décembre sur
la dernière quinzaine de décembre par
rapport à l'année dernière on a eu une
augmentation de de fréquentation de la
ville de 13 % c'est une super animation
ça met de la vie dans la ville et puis
les idées sont super chouettes mettre en
valeur des des sportifs
m franchement non c'est vachement
[Musique]
bien année olympique oblige 12 portraits
sont projetés sur les murs du
centrreeville pour rendre hommage au
sport local les lueur demande se
termineront le 10 février prochain avec
un spectacle éblouissant 200 drones
illumineront le ciel
[Musique]
menté et c'est bientôt l'heure de
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de demain et de ce
weekend demain matin il fera beau mais
il fera froid dans les evvelin compter
jusqu'à -5° à Mantel Jolie - 4 à Houdan
et - 3 à rambbouillé et Versailles
l'aprèsmidi le ciel sera toujours aussi
bleu sur l'ensemble du département au
niveau des températures ça ne sera plus
dans le négatif mais couvrez-vous bien
quand même puisqu'il fera en moyenne 1 à
2°gr pour les prévisions météo de ce
weekend vous pourrez profiter d'une
belle journée ensoleillé samedi mais là
encore il fera très froid jusqu'à - 6°
le matin et environ 2°gr l'après-midi
dimanche le ciel se couvre de nuages
mais les températures remontent un petit
peu il fera entre 0 et 2°g le matin et
environ 6 à 7°r l'après-midi c'est
l'heure à présent de passer à l'invité
du
[Musique]
78 et ce soir nous sommes avec la mre de
plaisir Joséphine colmansberger bonsoir
bonsoir bonne année 2024 merci mes
meilleurs vux également merci beaucoup
bonne année aussi à tous les habitants
de plaisir alors tout d'abord Joséphine
colmansberger que retenez-vous de
l'année 2023 dans vos vœux vous avez dit
que c'était une année pleine de
rebondissement oui pleine de
rebondissement d'abord parce qu'il y a
eu énormément de projets qui ont été je
dirais en aboutissement hein sur cette
année puis c'est une année de mi- mandat
donc on a pu faire vraiment un bilan de
de tout ce que nous avons fait pendant
cette période y compris bien sûr 2023 ça
nous a permis de voir ensemble avec les
élus et les habitants et bien que nous
étions à plus de 80 % de réalisation de
notre projet de ville que nous avions
présenté au début de ce mandat donc il y
a eu énormément de choses dans le cadre
sportif particulièrement puisqu'on a
fait beaucoup d'aménagement de sport
libre au niveau de la collectivité nous
avons également eu beaucoup de
réaménagements dans les écoles puisqu'il
y a des écoles qui ont été entièrement
refaites et puis réaménagées on a aussi
eu des travaux très importants au niveau
des voiries mais ce que je pourrais dire
c'est que surtout euh on a eu une année
qui s'est un petit peu associé aux
difficultés qu'on a pu ressentir au
niveau du national puisqu'il y a eu
quand même des émeutes assez importantes
dans notre ville également oui le
Commissar a été touchément exactement et
il y a aussi des petites entreprises qui
ont brûlé à plaisir donc on n' pas eu de
de bâtiments de de la ville vraiment
d'équipements publics qui ont brûlé et
heureusement mais c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui reste marqué sur cette
année 2023 puisque on est on a été quand
même un petit peu tous les uns et les
autres très étonné de cette vague très
très forte alors moi j'ai un tempérament
plutôt optimiste et ce que je retiens
surtout c'est que avec la la ville des
clés sous-bois on a pu aussi travailler
ensemble pour un nouveau projet donc ça
c'est quelque chose d'important just en
2023 la police municipale de plaisir
fusionne avec celle des clés sous-bois
quel premier bilan vous faites de cette
mutualisation alors déjà vous savez pour
monter un syndicat de police c'était pas
rien puisque ça n'existait pas et donc
avec la préfecture ça a été toute une
nouveauté administrative et le fait de
le faire aussi rapidement nous a permis
de voir qu'il y avait une vraie volonté
des deux collectivité qu'est-ce qu'on a
comme bilan ben c'est que déjà nous
devenons nous devenons plus attractifs
euh on a pu former les policiers pour
qu'ils soient armé parce que c'était une
attente euh aussi de la population
d'avoir je dirais une une police à la
fois très présente dans la proximité et
dans et et dans le quotidien mais aussi
je dirais pour avoir beaucoup plus de
policiers plus de bleus comme on dit sur
le sur le territoire moi ce que j'aime
au niveau de la police municipale c'est
justement qu'il y ait une proximité très
forte avec la population donc
satisfaction desécléciens qui ont vu
réapparaître une police municipale et
satisfaction à notre niveau au niveau de
plaisir puisque maintenant nous avons
beaucoup plus de policiers alors dans
les projets pour l'année 2024 il y a la
maison médicale qui devrait accueillir
peut-être ces nouveaux patients euh oui
et nouveau médecin aussi j'espère
vraiment vous savez que depuis 2020 nous
avons quand même 32 professionnels de
santé qui sont arrivés à plaisir alors
la difficulté ce sont les médecins
généralistes bien sûr on en a quand même
deux qui sont arrivés et cette maison
médicale les travaux commencent là
puisque la démolition de la maison qui
est dessus là qui est une maison qui qui
était complè complètement désinffecté et
bien va va être démoli et pendant 18
mois nous aurons les travaux de cette
belle maison médicale et bien sûr les
médecins qui actuellement sont à la
ruche des provisoires réintégreront et
il y en aura d'autres qui viendront les
rejoindre c'est très attendu et je
remercie encore le département des
ivelines qui nous a fortement accompagné
puisque c'est le département qui prend
en charge l'intégralité de de B des
dépenses qui sont liés à cette maison
médicale donc des médecins mais quels
seront les les autres services à
disposition des habitants ben il y aura
des médecins mais aussi des infirmiers
il y aura des kinés il y aura toute une
série de de spécialistes euh nous sommes
nous serons à même d'en d'en accueillir
beaucoup plus que une quinzaine donc
voilà actuellement vous savez nous avons
la chance d'avoir un agent un équivalent
temps plein à plaisir qui n'est pas
obligatoire c'est pas dans c'est pas
dans nos obligations de ville mais j'ai
voulu qu'on ait un agent à pleintemps
qui s'occupe justement de chercher des
médecins et de faire du marketing de
notre ville pour essayer d'attirer alors
je veux pas spoer les autres villes mais
en tout cas si on peut les faire venir à
plaisir on le fait puisque vous savez
qu'on les accompagne aussi avec un
accompagnement à 10000 € pour chaque
généraliste qui vient s'installer chez
nous parmi les autres travaux prévus
cette année la rénovation du château un
château qui est d'ailleurs classé
monument historique qu'est-ce qui est
prévu concrètement alors déjà je peux
vous dire que pendant 2 ans plus de 2
ans il y a eu des études de faites à
l'intérieur de ce château comme vous
venez de le rappeler c'est un château
effectivement euh qui est protégé et
donc euh nous avons eu toute une série
d'experts qui sont venus voir dans quel
état il était et qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
bien sûr rénover à l'intérieur il sera
refait intégralement puisque nous devons
refaire la toiture qui n'est plus en
état nous devons refaire l'intérieur
l'intérieur les murs la réhabilitation
euh de l'acoustique et du chauffage qui
sera en géothermie et effectivement
refaire toutes les façades et plus de
100 fenêtres euh euh ça va prendre du
temps oui et en et ça va nous coûter
relativement cher puisque ça va coûter
plus de 3 millions à la ville mais c'est
une facture de plus de 8 millions et qui
est fortement accompagnée par le
Département l'État la Région donc je les
en remercie bien sûr très gros chantier
qui va permettre pendant 2 ans au
conservateur de musique de partir et
d'aller dans un autre bâtiment
provisoirement de revenir par il sera la
aise dans le quartier de la
parce que nous avons réhabilité un très
gros bâtiment à la aise qui aujourd'hui
accueille des enfants qui sont en
attente d'une construction d'une
nouvelle école et donc il y aura un
switch ces enfantsl vont partir en
septembre au niveau de la nouvelle école
le Conservatoire va intégrer ce bâtiment
à la aise et ensuite ils reviendront
dans le château qui sera complètement
rénové avec une acoustique adaptée au
conservatoire et également la
médiathèque va déménager dans une école
à doudé et reviendra
pas du tout dans le château mais dans un
nouveau bâtiment pour le centrebourg
d'accord côté espace vert là aussi il y
a des travaux puisqu'il y aura des
travaux au niveau du parc des quatre
saisons avec notamment un parcours
d'orientation des jeux pour enfants et
des équipements sportifs tout à fait on
a travaillé en partenariat avec saanttin
en Yveline puisque le nord du parc des
quatre saisons appartient plutôt la
trame verte appartient à Saint-Quentin
et nous on a travaillé sur le reste pour
que ça devienne plus familial plus
ouvert aux enfants et à aux adolescents
également ce sont des travaux qui ont
pris beaucoup de temps pour démarrer ça
fait plus de 2 3 ans qu'on attendait ça
y est ça démarre on m'a dit que c'était
c'était bon pour voilà dans quelques
semaines les travaux commencent
également il y en a pour 6 à 9 mois et
alors dans les autres grands projets de
la ville déjà qui durent depuis
plusieurs années la transformation du
valiibou en écoquartier où est-ce que le
dossier en est alors euh c'est
effectivement vous avez raison ça c'est
commencé il y a longtemps eu on sait on
connaît le montant des financements qui
sont très important hein qui qui
avoisine les 75 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans le
démarrage de la construction du groupe
scolaire qui va réunir pardon tous les
enfin les trois écoles et le centre de
loisirs donc ça c'est un premier travaux
second travaux démolition de deux
bâtiments puisqu'il va y avoir des
réaménagements au niveau routier alors
plutôt voiries on va dire parce qu'on
dit c'est une route non ce sont des
voiries à l'intérieur du quartier on
travaille avec les commerçants
actuellement parce que nous devons
refaire l'intégralité du centre
commercial ça veut dire donc
reconstruire des bâtiments avec tout ce
qui est commercial en bas d'immeuble et
ensuite démolir l'ancien et puis
également aujourd'hui on réfléchit
toujours à notre garage solidaire et
également au niveau de la jeunesse par
rapport à des locaux ouverts aux jeunes
on a déjà
ouvert un local qui aujourd'hui est
fermé pour diverses raisons et il va
être dédoublé déplacé et on pense le
faire assez rapidement d'accord donc ça
ce sont les futurs projets à l'horizon
2028 euh moi je je dirais que
l'intégralité du du du quartier sera
terminé dans les 4 5 ans qui viennent
donc l'année prochaine j'espère bien que
on verra vraiment l'école déjà commencer
et on verra déjà des choses bouger
autour du centre commercial et surtout
de la jeunesse c'est pour moi c'est
prioritaire alors toujours parmi les
grands projets de la ville et au niveau
de l'urbanisme le réaménagement du
centre ville qui devrait s'étendre sur
22 hectares quelles sont les grandes
orientations de ce projet alors c'est un
parc habité on a travaillé vous savez le
centrebourg a commencé par la
réhabilitation de l'église ensuite on a
fait le parc ensuite on a fait la place
de l'église maintenant on fait le
château donc c'est une vraie trame qui
traverse la collectivité qui qui le
proch les prochains travaux c'est la
halle du marché qui va être complètement
réhabilité avec une ouverture sur
l'extérieur la médiathèque grande
médiatèque qui doit être construite fin
mandat le mandat prochain et puis
également le rue tout le réaménagement
du rue qui va devenir une vraie
promenade et ça va être un parc habité
effectivement de 22 hactares où à peine
40 % de l'espace sera constructible pour
pouvoir y mettre des logements mais
plutôt vers le nord là où effectivement
il y a une densité urbaine vers le sud
du côté de la halle ça sera plutôt des
espaces verts et un parc avec des
jardins familiaux et enfin Joséphine
colmasberger pour terminer cet entretien
on vous laisse une carte blanche vous
pouvez aborder le sujet de votre choix
la jeunesse la jeunesse parce que à
plaisir nous avons toute une démarche
accompagnée par l'État entre autre sur
la cité éducative sur la politique de la
ville et on s'aperçoit que que c'est la
3ème année que nous avons toute cette
dynamique là et et je suis en train de
travailler avec les services de la ville
pour avoir une feuille de route beaucoup
plus précise encore de tout cet
accompagnement à la jeunesse quand je
dis jeunesse c'est toute la jeunesse la
jeunesse qui effectivement présente
quelques difficultés et on peut le
constater à certains moments et la
jeunesse qui réussit et et qui va bien
donc on doit valoriser également ceux
qui vont bien on doit valoriser ces
jeunes qui fond du sport de la culture
ou rien parce que il y a des jeunes qui
étudient et à côté ils ont pas de
passion particulière mais je trouve que
nous n'avons pas suffisamment développer
peut-être cette feuille de route précise
sur la jeunesse donc avec les différents
services le scolaire la jeunesse mais
également la culture le sport on est en
train de travailler là-dessus donc les
autres projets avancent ils sont bien
enclenchés là c'est un grand enjeu pour
2024 et donc je voilà je m'y attellele
vraiment et bien merci beaucoup
Joséphine berger d'avoir accepté notre
invitation encore une nouvelle fois
bonne année 2024 c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur tv78
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous